cabal is no stranger to the cold
freezing temperatures are normal in
December but this year people are
struggling to find the fuel they need to
stay warm
ER
we don't have anything to bend in the
winter there is no humanitarian Aid nor
proper food to eat I'm disabled and
can't work and my kids go and gather
plastic paper and other stuff so that we
could burn and keep ourselves warm
Shanna was in his family of nine are
among thousands of people in Afghanistan
who are struggling as coal and wood
prices surge
it's the second winter Afghans have
spent under the Taliban since it retook
power in the spring of 2021. with
billions of dollars of the country's
cash reserves Frozen by the U.S the
government is short of money and
struggling to provide basic services
the global energy crunch is also making
life harder
this year full prices have increased by
about 46 dollars per ton most of the
buyers come and buy only up to 20 kilos
of coal or wood because of economic
hardship
the Taliban leadership says it's
considering a cap on domestic prices but
it's unclear how much help the
government can offer thousands of people
who fled conflict drought and floods in
the countryside now face a freezing
winter in Kabul and other cities
and the United Nations world food
program is warning the country faces its
worst famine in 20 years
for many in Afghanistan life is looking
more than ever like a fight for survival
and the taliban's promise of a peaceful
and prosperous country at best a distant
one 30 a car Al Jazeera